mona bonjour vous trouvez devant le
sénat que révèle le rapport de la
commission d' enquête sur l'incendié de
lubrizol
alors il faut savoir que cette
commission enquête a été créée le 10
octobre dernier elle a pour but
d'évaluer l'intervention de l'état dans
la gestion des conséquences
environnementales et sanitaires et
économiques de cet incendie d'origine
lubrizol en septembre dernier le rapport
a donc était présenté aux alentours de
8h30 cette commission d' enquête du
sénat est bien là tout d'abord dénoncé
et des angles morts inacceptables dans
la politique des prix de prévention des
risques industriels en france
hervé maurey qui est le président de
cette commission d' enquête a indiqué
que le suivi sanitaire du ministère de
la santé était problématique et selon
vue pour le moment il est impossible de
définir l'impact sanitaire cas qui a eu
cet cet incendie sur la population
elisabeth bornel de son côté qui est la
ministre de la transition écologique a
été pointé du doigt pour sa
responsabilité elle qui avait promis une
augmentation des contrôles de 50% d'ici
2022 selon hervé maurey ceci est tout
simplement peu réaliste ce rapport
épingle également l'ex ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn qui a qualifié qui
selon hervé maurey encore une fois qui a
qualifié ce suivi sanitaire tardif est
incomplet les élus ont donc estimé que
les sanctions qui ont été prises jusqu'à
présent n'ont pas été suffisantes
il faut savoir que cette commission
denquête elle a été menée avec un peu
près 80 audition plusieurs personnalités
ont donc été entendus notamment le
président directeur général du groupe
lubrizol eric chenu re le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner l'ex
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn ou
encore elisabeth borne à ministre de la
transition écologique on a également
entendu yvon robert le maire ps de rouen
et quelques experts et syndicalistes ont
également été entendus alors il faut le
savoir depuis cet incendie les
mi temps 2 roues on se plaignent de
d'une odeur très forte de maux de tête
de vomissements donne aux et cela bien
susciter une inquiétude au sein de la
population qui s'inquiète à des risques
sanitaires sur le long terme
la catastrophe avait elle provoquait à
22 kilomètres de nuage de fumée noire et
près de 9500 tonnes de produits
chimiques avaient été brûlés une zone
d'ombré subsistent donc l'anc est en
cours menée par le parquet de paris n'a
pas encore pu déterminer la cause de cet
incendie
voilà un modèle or en direct donc du
slam merci pour toutes ces précisions